et nouvelle mobilisation contre
l'islamophobie à paris plusieurs
associations se sont donné rendez-vous
pour dénoncer le projet de loi contre
les séparatismes on retrouve à notre
reporter nuque est léger place du
châtelet à paris
bonjour lucas alors quelle est
l'ambiance bien ces manifestants ils
viennent de démarrer l'humanité d'une
manifestation vers la place de la
république
cette manifestation avait été lancé à
l'appel d'un front contre l'islamophobie
un second qui regroupe plusieurs
organisations dont des organisations
cultuelles bien sûr mais aussi des
militants limite antiracistes ont mis
tant de gauche les militants féministes
et tout vous perçoivent et bien
critiquer les dérives islamophobes du
gouvernement c'est leur terme en tout
cas et notamment ils craignent un
contrôle accru du culte musulman par
l'état c'est une de leurs craintes
ils craignent aussi des dissolutions
massive d'organisation avec la loi
contre les séparatismes je vous propose
d'écouter des manifestants que j'ai pu
interviewer au début de cette
manifestation
on est venu là pour dénoncer la loi
séparatisme et l'islamophobie qui en
découlent
clairement nous on est une association
de femmes dont convient d enfin on vient
d'énoncer l'aspect genre et de la loi
séparatisme qui
qui
kim est entre guillemets sous tutelle la
femme notamment la famille humaine qui
porte le voile
en fait on nous reproche la restriction
des libertés individuelles et
collectives
donc que ce soit les articles sur
l'obligation d'enlever le voile pour les
femmes salariés dans le privé mais
intervient dans le public
que ce soit les liberté associative que
ce soit la charte des humains qui est
aussi présente donc globalement c'est
vraiment ça en fait et les libertés
individuelles qui sont restreintes et
aussi toute la dimension sécuritaire et
liberticide qui va venir checker ce que
fait chaque association comme pourquoi
des menaces quant aux subventions
ce fou contre l'islamophobie il a lancé
plusieurs appels à manifester dans
plusieurs villes de france comme lyon
marseille ou encore montpellier
il espère ainsi faire infléchir la
position du gouvernement dont ils
estiment qu'il a autre chose à faire en
période de crise notamment sanitaires
merci et beaucoup le cas pour toutes ces
précisions